fifteen-year-old ilya molotkov was
studying acrobatics at the circus school
in kiev until the war broke out he's now
living as a refugee in germany trying to
continue his studies he sends videos of
his exercises to his coach who is still
in
i really enjoyed going to the circus
school and to rehearse the response from
the audience made me happy
but everything has changed since the
start of the war
by bringing ukrainian belarusian and
other international artists together
this dutch circus director hopes that a
long tradition can be continued despite
the war the messages
let us hope that one time the whole
world's going to be a circus world
because
we are the proof that it's possible to
work live
together with
so much different nationalities together
[Applause]
[Music]
olga mahutova from belarus performing on
the so-called russian bar with two
ukrainian colleagues is one example
[Applause]
with artists who remain professional we
still have a good relationship russians
below russians it doesn't matter
i lost a lot of friends i worked in
russia for a long time we don't
communicate with each other
[Music]
circus has long been an art form that
has brought ukrainian and russian
performers together but because of the
war that's now only possible in
countries as far away as the netherlands
but for some sharing a stage together is
difficult with all that's been going on
anastasia safarian managed to flee the
ukrainian city of igbin which was
heavily attacked by russian forces she
said for now she can't perform together
with her russian colleagues
i can't do this now
i would feel i would betray my people
because they are fighting for my country
and people are dying at the moment that
would not be possible for me
[Music]
a few days before the show several
russian artists cancelled despite their
trauma anastasia and the other
performers hope that one day circus can
again bring russian and ukrainian
performers together step fasten al
jazeera dordrecht in the netherlands